bom mesmo não sabendo como que nós seres
humanos somos capazes de perceber e
compreender e de tomar decisões
nós já buscamos o desenvolvimento de
sistemas e dispositivos inteligentes
isso já existe isso já é realidade e
inteligência artificial é a área da
computação que trabalha com pesquisa e
desenvolvimento de sistemas inteligentes
acho que essa substância explica melhor
a língua e hoje eu vou conversar com
vocês sobre esse tema bastante até
intrigante e polêmico em alguns casos
mas será que um dia nós seremos
dominados pela inteligência artificial
quem de vocês a região aos vencedores do
oscar 2016
é como a china exibe o mecanismo
eletrônico que usa uma inteligência
artificial e millar a inteligência dos
humanos
como será que isso funciona
será que isso muda a nossa forma de
perceber o mundo será que isso muda as
relações humanas quanto de ser a ficção
ainda mais inteligência artificial já é
realidade ela já está disponível nos
sistemas visíveis e nos invisíveis por
exemplo
um carro autônomo vocês sabem que em
2014 o estado da bahia
houve mais de duas mil e 500 mortes em
acidentes de trânsito e que segundo
pesquisas a maioria dela num aconteceu
por imprudência dos seus condutores
esse carro é o carro da google onde você
entra aperta um botão e diz pra onde
quer ir
vocês já imaginaram o quanto isso pode
mudar a nossa forma de trabalhar a nossa
forma de nos relacionarmos eu posso usar
por exemplo esse carro como uma extensão
do meu escritório
quantas horas vocês gastam por semana
dirigindo
já imaginaram entrar num carro como esse
de manhã fazer uma conexão consigo
refletir e chegar no trabalho tranqüilo
leve e tem um excelente dia de trabalho
mas isso é bastante polêmico lá porque
imagine o seguinte os taxistas que em
função já criar um grande movimento e
função da utilização de um dispositivo
de um aplicativo como berlim
imagina como será em algum momento que
não vai demorar
eles perderem os seus próprios empregos
os carros autônomos mas essa realidade
já existe no brasil não é só no google
na agricultura brasileira
esse carro
que é conduzido sem motorista é
utilizado para pulverização de
agrotóxicos os sistemas inteligentes
também estão em muitos outros
dispositivos como na medicina
esse é um robô cirurgião no brasil e são
paulo nós já temos uma sala de cirurgia
híbrida para cirurgias cardíacas onde
parte da cirurgia é feito por um robô ea
outra parte pelos médicos especialistas
e sistemas então estão em muitos outros
lugares
por outro lado já fizeram alguma compra
que foi sugerido por um sistema
você gostou do resultado
você já recebeu uma sugestão no facebook
e gostou daquela sugestão como será que
isso acontece
será que você contou como fazer
ou será que o sistema automaticamente
descobriu o seu comportamento o seu
perfil
nessa linha conhecemos um caso muito
interessante que é o time e aí que é um
multi do twitter que tinha um propósito
de aprender a conversar com os jovens
com menos de 24 horas do seu lançamento
ele teve que ser retirado do ar e ele
foi retirado do ar por apresentar
comportamentos inadequados racistas
antes feministas entre outros
perceba o seguinte quando essa conta foi
pro ar
ele não sabia conversar e ele aprendeu
esses comportamentos inadequados com os
jovens que conversaram com ele em menos
de 24 horas
olhem a velocidade do aprendizado
quanto gasta uma criança como aquela
lado início pra aprender com isso a
máquina hoje é o trabalhador mudou
antigamente o trabalhador utilizava a
máquina como uma ferramenta hoje é o
próprio trabalhador
eles podem me perguntar solange mas e aí
os empregos como vão ficar bom no japão
na metade do século passado eles
importavam trabalhadores
hoje eles exporta tecnologia que será
que aconteceu por lá mas até onde vai o
limite da inteligência artificial
com essa evolução o que nós esperamos
nós podemos usar um martelo cometeu um
assassinato mas nós podemos usar o mesmo
martelo e lá e utilizar ele na
construção de uma casa
nós podemos comandar um drone que vai
até uma vida que está em perigo em alto
mar e salvar aquela vida mas esse mesmo
throne pode ser conduzido a fazer um
grande mas aqui nós podemos usar a
inteligência artificial para aprender e
recomendar uma compra
assim como podemos utilizar da mesma
inteligência para espionar os nossos
dados aí na internet
a tecnologia está nas mãos dos homens
cabe a cada um de nós decidir o que
fazer com ela
obrigado ao tabagismo por me permitir a
conexão com vocês e com salvador
[Aplausos]